ja und der fall phoenix hat mittlerweile
eine ganze branche in mitleidenschaft
gezogen die fleischbranche trotzdem gibt
es immer noch menschen die es lieben
genau in dieser zu arbeiten
eine von ihnen ist julia reichmann sie
ist gerade mal 19 jahre alt und macht
eine ausbildung zur metzgerin mit dem
schwerpunkt schlachten am sonntag war
sie im politik talk hierbei bild die
richtigen fragen zu sehen da wollen wir
einmal reinschauen
warum möchtest du das werden tiere töten
das ist doch das ist doch eklig und wie
kannst du das nur und habe ich immer
geantwortet ja es geht einfach aber ihr
wollt ja auch alle fleisch essen oder
also muss er auch jemand da sein der die
tiere tötet und wenn man das aber in
einem schönen umfeld für die tiere macht
schon angefangen bei der haltung der
tiere dann finde ich das auch irgendwo
in ordnung und wir haben julia reichmann
in ihrem kleinen betrieb besucht beim
schwein schlachten
zu hause eine eigene metzgerei im
schwarzwald und das war schon immer
eigentlich mein traum auch die
ausbildung und eben fürs geschäft dann
später zu übernehmen natürlich sah schon
in der kleinen in der roten kiste hat
dort mit rüstungen gespielt werden der
papa neben dran gearbeitet hat also
schon seit baby an war ich dabei kann
man sagen dass ich so viel machen kann
dass ich zerlegen kann dass es
schlachten kann
das ist einfach jeden tag irgendwie auch
was anderes ist und nicht jeden tag an
wand oder so wo ich jedes mal die
gleiche bewegung machen werden auch
andere aufträge es ist ständig was neu
ist einfach das gefällt mir sehr
es ist im prinzip meine arbeit wie
andere großbanken gehe ich einfach um
slim auszudrücken tiere töten
aber wenn ich in den raum rein kommen
dann ist es für mich einfach den
schalter umlegen und dann kommt für mich
einfach nur darauf an dass die tiere
schon vorher gelebt haben dass sie schön
behandelt werden auch bis zum schlachten
bisschen betäuben hin und dann bin ich
eigentlich zufrieden wenn die nicht
leiden dann ist es für mich völlig in
ordnung